herzlich willkommen das ist zdf heute
live an einem montag an dem sich
millionen bürgerinnen und bürger fragen
ob in ihrem vorgarten vielleicht bald
ein atomklo steht denn heute hat die
bundes gesellschaft für endlagerung bg
verkündet an 90 standorten könnte
theoretisch in zukunft ein
atommüllendlager stehen auf rein
wissenschaftlicher fakten basis darüber
reden wir heute abend wie immer eure
fragen in die kommentare und wenn ihr
uns über die zdf heute app nutzt dann
bitte eure fragen auch an diese adresse
schicken
hier bei mir im studio begrüße ich ganz
herzlich volker angres den leiter der
zdf umwelt redaktion volker schön dass
du da und in berlin begrüße ich mit
steffen kanitz einen der diesen
zwischenberichten mit erarbeitet hat den
geschäftsführer der bg schönen guten tag
alles gut namen nach mainz er kam mit 70
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
haben seit 2017 quasi auf diesen montag
hingearbeitet der 29 september 2020 um
diesen zwischenbericht vorzustellen nun
ist er vorgestellt dieser tag geht fast
zu ende
wie ist er gelaufen ich glaube erst gut
gelaufen weil die republik festgestellt
hat dass wir in der tat den ersten
wichtigen meilenstein auf dem weg hin zu
den best möglichen endlagerstandort in
deutschland geschaffen haben und
gleichzeitig aber auch allen klar
geworden ist bei 54% betroffenheit der
bundesdeutschen fläche sind wir schon
noch ein gutes stück entfernt von einem
echten endlagerstandort wie genau die
diskussion heute gelaufen ist und wie
sie weiterlaufen könnte das schauen wir
uns gleich an und erst eine kleine
zusammenfassung zum thema wohin mit dem
hochradioaktiven restmüll aus
jahrzehntelanger atomenergie aus
geologischer sicht kommt dafür halb
deutschland infrage 90 gebiete eignen
sich für ein atommüll endlager nicht
mehr mit dabei der salzstock in gorleben
dafür aber berlin das saarland ist das
einzige bundesland was nicht
frage kommt die anforderungen sind klar
definiert in mindestens 300 meter unter
der erdoberfläche sollen die atommüll
behälter sicher lagern für eine million
jahre
sie dürfen dort also nicht von erdbeben
oder vulkanen gefährdet sein
außerdem müssen die behälter mögliche
eiszeiten überstehen können
in eingeschlossene gesteinsformationen
aus salz ton oder granit müssen am ende
1900 castorbehälter reinpassen
die im grunde keiner vor seiner haustür
haben will
termin und damit ist auch schon klar
dass das ganze eine politische große
dimension hat ich würde nur gerne
erstmal bei der wissenschaftlichen
bleiben volker ist dass der neustart den
man sich erwünscht hat ist das ein guter
neustart
ja ich denke schon dass wir unbedingt
erforderlich denn die alte debatte war
so verfahren
gorleben ist ja nicht nur irgendein
standort eines möglichen endlagers
gewesen sondern geradezu das symbol für
die auseinandersetzung über die frage
brauchen wir atom ja oder nein und was
machen wir mit dem müll und von daher
gesehen war es einfach verbrannt und es
war allerhöchste zeit dass ein neues
verfahren in gang kommt man kann
natürlich sagen es ist deutlich zu spät
in gang gekommen wir haben natürlich
jahre verloren das hätte schon längst
früher passieren müssen aber auch dass
zur erinnerung es gab auch ein hin und
her bei der frage wie geht es eigentlich
mit der atomenergie weiter und es war
einen moment lang so dass die
atomlaufzeiten sogar verlängert worden
sind dann kam fukushima und dann ging es
wieder andersrum also das ist nicht
gerade eine eine geradlinige politik an
der stelle kann man natürlich alles
erklären aber wir sind jetzt an dem
punkt insofern ist das ein guter tag
heute dass wir jetzt einen schritt
weiter sind in einem noch jahre
dauernden verfahren wie wird denn er
kann jetzt dieses verfahren jetzt laufen
was wird man bei diesem neustart jetzt
anders machen als zu den verfahren die
man in der vergangenheit gewählt hat
wenn man davon verfahren überhaupt
sprechen kann
ja ich glaube schon dass man von einem
verfahren sprechen kann das verfahren
ist gesetzlich kodifiziert im
sogenannten standortauswahlgesetz diese
standortauswahl gesetzt ist in einem
überparteilichen konsens zwischen
bundestag und bundesrat 2017 geschieden
worden und das novum da war dass man im
vorfeld eine expertenkommission
eingesetzt hat die endlager kommission
die die kriterien für die
standortauswahl wissenschaftsbasierte
erarbeitet hat der gesetzgeber hat diese
kriterien eins zu eins übernommen und
wiederum wir als bundes gesellschaft für
entladung als vorhaben trägerin haben
jetzt in einem ersten schritt diese
kriterien 11 abgearbeitet das verfahren
ist angelegt auf transparenz und
bürgerbeteiligung partizipation
das heißt ein unterschied ist einerseits
dass die kriterien von anfang an
feststehen
sie sind für
nachvollziehbar und transparent und
gleichzeitig haben wir aber auch eine
verpflichtende
öffentlichkeitsbeteiligung mit
weitgehenden rechten es gibt ein
nationales begleit gremium dass ein
umfangreiches akteneinsichtsrecht hat
bei der bg also kriterien von anfang an
fest zu legen sich daran nicht nur zu
orientieren sondern sie eins zu eins
abzuarbeiten und umzusetzen die starke
wissenschaftsbasierte des verfahrens und
gleichzeitig die sehr klare
bürgerbeteiligung mit klaren nach
prüfungs rechtlich verankert sind das
ist sicherlich ein novum in diesem
verfahren nun gab es allerdings schon
heute an nach diesem ersten schritt
dieses dreiteiligen verfahrens kritik
ich sind hier mal den bayerischen
umweltminister thorsten glauber von den
freien wählern der sagt das verfahren
ist weder schlank noch zielgerichtet
gewesen mehr als 50 prozent der
landesfläche der bundesrepublik mehr
ohne der bundesrepublik deutschland und
mehr als zwei drittel der landesfläche
des freistaats bayern als möglichen
standort auszuweisen
das kann auch ein geologie student im
dritten semester
was antworten sie haben glaube ich
antwortete ihm dass das verfahren genau
so angelegt war wir haben nicht die
aufgabe einen geeigneten standort zu
finden sollen wir haben die aufgabe den
bestmöglichen und hat den potenziell
geeigneten zu finden das heißt in dieser
ersten frühen phase ging es darum den
bestmöglichen standort nicht alleine
dadurch zu verlieren dass wir zu wenig
oder zu ungenaue daten hatten
und insofern musste man nach diesem
vorsichtsprinzip genauso vorgehen wie
wir jetzt vorgegangen sind ich bin der
festen überzeugung wir werden am ende
nur dann einen standort bekommen der
auch toleriert werden kann wenn wir den
primat der wissenschaft folgen und wenn
wir die rollenteilung zwischen vorhaben
trägerinnen die wissenschaftsbasierte
entscheidungsvorlagen erarbeitet die
dann über einen prüfungsprozess durch
die rechtsaufsicht laufen durch
bürgerbeteiligung laufen anschließend
dem gesetzgeber vorgegeben werden die
entscheidungsgrundlage kann nicht
politisch sein sondern sie muss
wissenschaftsbasierte und dann muss
politik am ende auf dieser basis
entscheiden können vielleicht kann man
noch ganz kurz grenzen karls soweit ich
weiß sind das ja auch die daten die
jetzt schon erhoben worden sind die
bereits bekannt waren also das sind
sozusagen eine statistische auswertung
von vorhandenen geologischen daten das
ist der erste schritt das erklärt auch
warum so viele gebiete ausgewiesen
worden sind im nächsten schritt wird man
dann ja vor ort erkunden und geologische
bohrung z
wir machen und in aller übernächsten
schritt dann gibt es auch noch bergwerke
die man einrichten wird um in den
untergrund einzusteigen da genau zu
gucken und das denke ich wird dann dazu
führen dass die möglichen gebiete eben
immer weniger werden ob dann bayern
immer noch stolzer eigentümer von ganz
vielen gebieten sein wird das weiß ich
nicht keine ahnung aber das ist den die
nächsten schritte jeden fall hat dieser
erste wie sie gerade geschildert haben
bericht zwischenbericht auch
festgestellt dass es gorleben nicht ist
hat dich das überrascht ja ja muss ich
schon sagen also wir haben uns ja lange
zeit gar nicht mehr mit dem thema
beschäftigt und insofern ist das auch
journalistisch gesehen heute ein
interessanter tag war jetzt die
diskussion wieder losgeht gorleben
seinerzeit ist glaube ich ja dass hier
heute herausgekommen nicht nach
wissenschaftlichen kriterien festgelegt
worden
wenn ich mich ganz richtig erinnere war
es mehr oder weniger der einfachste weg
der politisch einfachste weg gorleben
damals gab es die ddr noch und gorleben
liegt hart an der grenze zur früheren
ddr und hat mir einfach gesagt ja wo
können wir ein endlager hin bauen wo
möglichst wenig widerstand entsteht also
richtung osten hat man gesagt nur dass
überhaupt kein widerstand da gibt es
erstmal im grenzstreifen der wohn keine
und dann kommen irgendwann da hinten
paar dörfer und bei gorleben hat man
gesagt auch die im wendland bis die
gemerkt haben dass wir dann endlager
bauen ist es längst fertig völlige
fehleinschätzung die wendländer sind auf
die barrikaden gegangen
das haben wir nun wirklich mitgekriegt
und deswegen ist politik da gescheitert
weil es eben nicht transparent war und
nicht wissenschaftlich begründet war
und dieses das hat man glaube ich jetzt
auch gelernt und deswegen ist dieses
verfahren möglicherweise auf den ersten
blick so umfangreich und so umständlich
aber ich denke es gibt überhaupt keine
alternative dazu vielleicht sogar noch
im gegenteil man muss es möglicherweise
noch transparente an der einen oder
anderen stelle machen und möglicherweise
noch mehr bürgerbeteiligung ermöglicht
das werden die nächsten monate und jahre
dann sehen ob das notwendig ist
er kann jetzt können sie sich vorstellen
wenn man diese gorleben sache anschaut
dass dann viele bürger im land sagen aha
wenn ich es einfach so machen wie die im
wendland und monatelang jahrelang
jahrzehntelang auch ordentlich auf die
barrikaden gehen dann kann ich das
endlager form einer
haustür verhindern aber das ist ja genau
nicht
die botschaft des heutigen tages gebot
schafft des heutigen tages ist dass
jeder standort unabhängig von seiner
historie in diesem verfahren geprüft
wird und sich anhand von
wissenschaftlichen kriterien messen dort
messen lassen muss und dann eben
entweder weiter betrachtet wird oder
nach basis der wissenschaftlichen
kriterien der ausscheidet ist war auch
damals schon umstritten ob gorleben
weiter im verfahren bleibt oder nicht
und es hat sich die meinung durchgesetzt
dass in einem verfahren das mit der
weißen deutschlandkarte beginnt kein
standort auch nicht derjenige standort
der eine zugegebenermaßen schwierigen
story hat nur aufgrund dieser historie
und dieses protestes ausgeschieden
werden kann sondern er muss ich eben
auch in den wissenschaftlichen kriterien
messen wir noch mal erklären zu gorleben
wir haben in gorleben die
mindestanforderung erfüllt wir haben
mindestens 100 meter mächtigkeit und wir
haben mindestens 300 meter tiefe aber
wir haben keine günstige geologische
gesamtsituation das heißt die frage der
geeignetheit gorlebens wurde in diesem
verfahren nicht überprüft es geht darum
den bestmöglichen standort zu finden und
das können wir heute sagen dass es
gorleben jedenfalls nicht vielleicht
liegt ja in bayern und da gerät stets in
die wissenschaft massiv die politik
hinein
der bayerische ministerpräsident markus
söder hat sich da heute sehr dezidiert
geäußert was wir nur wollen des fairness
nebst gefühl dass diese fairness im
moment im politischen prozess
ein bisschen fehlt nach dem motto am
liebsten alles nach bayern die bayern
soll das nehmen die haben doch mal von
der kernenergie profitiert er kann jetzt
haben sie mit so viel politischem
gegenwind aus dem süden gerechnet
ja ich muss einmal sagen wir sind ja
diejenige institution die jetzt die
entscheidungsgrundlagen liefert über die
dann politik zu entscheiden hat und die
entscheidungsgrundlage kann nur dann
funktionieren wenn alle bundesländer
daten liefern und alle länder inklusive
der bayern haben die daten geliefert die
wir brauchten drei gebiete auszuweisen
unter anderem deswegen gibt es ja auch
teilgebiete in bayern das ist völlig
klar dass diese diskussion jetzt auch
politisch geführt wird dass es
nachvollziehbar
meine hoffnung ist dass darunter nicht
der konsens wackelt denn das brauchen
wir am ende schon wir brauchen auch die
politische unterstützung für diesen
transparenten und neuen weg im volker zu
bayern bayern hatte glaube ich das erste
kernkraftwerk überhaupt und auch
wahrscheinlich mit das letzte
in zwei von sechs die noch laufen stehen
in bayern werden spätestens 2022
abgeschaltet
markus söder hat er gerade gesagt bayern
hat von der kernkraft profitiert aber
und das ist eben der nächste schritt ein
endlager bitte nicht in bayern
na ja also das kann ich ehrlich gesagt
nicht nachvollziehen kann ich es ja
gerade noch mal erläutert wie das
verfahren war auch bayern hat zugestimmt
dass ja schon ein paar jahre her als das
entschieden worden ist und genau nach
diesem verfahren ist jetzt vorgegangen
worden und ich weiß nicht klar ist es
raus gekommen dass in bayern
der größte anteil an möglichen standorte
neben liegt das regt offenbar die
bayerische staatsregierung dann auch an
der stelle das haben wir gerade gesehen
aber ehrlich gesagt das ist fair bis
dahin und jetzt muss man einfach gucken
wie der weitere prozess läuft und das
muss man sich auch noch mal erinnern wir
erinnern uns ja heute schon eine ganze
menge gorleben hatten wir schon da gab
es mal einen atomminister in den 1900
1950 er anfang der 1960 er jahre unter
hieß franz josef strauß da wurde die
atomenergie massiv nach vorne gebracht
an der stelle
und jetzt sagt bayern eben nur wir
wollen aber kein endlager haben und das
ist unfair irgendwie dass krieg nicht
zusammen ehrlich gesagt da muss man
wirklich diesen transparenten prozess
erst mal laufen lassen wenn man meint
der prozess sei nicht in ordnung gibt es
auch die möglichkeiten das zu
hinterfragen man kann es auch wieder in
den bundestag zurück spiegeln da wird
ohnehin alle paar schritte muss der
bundestag wieder abstimmen und
entscheiden das sind demokratisch fähre
möglichkeiten ich kann da ehrlich gesagt
kein problem darin erkennt man muss es
jetzt einfach so tun
liebes zdf heute live team
ich glaube wir haben ein problem mit den
user kommentaren
zumindest habe ich einst ich weiß nicht
ob ihr das lesen könnt ich finde es
nämlich schade wenn wir überhaupt keine
user kommentare einfließen lassen können
in die sendung einen hätte ich hier
markus maaß schreibt über youtube das
ist nicht deutschlands atommüll das ist
der müll einiger unternehmen die
millionen verdient haben als sie den
müll erzeugt haben können die sich bitte
selber um ihren müll kümmern
er kann jetzt wissen müll ist das denn
um den sie sich dann kümmern
na das ist erst einmal der müll
der in deutschland produziert worden ist
mit dem strom erzeugt worden ist von dem
die bundesrepublik und damit natürlich
auch die bürger und bürgerinnen des
landes profitiert haben
das ist natürlich mit der von
unternehmen produziert worden ist das
stimmt die dafür bezahlt haben bezahlt
haben in form von geld an den start
in der letzten legislaturperiode ist
hier eine vereinbarung getroffen worden
zum einen eine neuordnung der
organisation der endlagerfrage aber auch
eine neue organisation der finanzierung
die energieversorgungsunternehmen die
geld verdient haben haben insgesamt 24
milliarden an den staat bezahlt und
diese 24 milliarden liegen am öffentlich
rechtlichen fonds aus dem die
endlagersuche bezahlt wird
ja da muss man natürlich sagen die 24
milliarden das war ein schnäppchen
die endlagersuche und dann der betrieb
eines endlagers wird dramatisch viel
teurer sein da hat sich die
energiewirtschaft wirklich sehr billig
rausgekauft das muss man schon kritisch
an dieser stelle sagen aber auch das ist
wieder der politischen situation zu der
zeit geschuldet ist ging um den
atomausstieg und die betreiber von
kernkraftwerken mussten vor der
regulären laufzeit rausgehen das heißt
das ist ein finanzieller ein
wirtschaftlicher verlust und darum wurde
gestritten und was er kann jetzt gerade
gesagt hat das ist dabei herausgekommen
aber bezogen auf die kosten die noch
anstehen ist das wirklich ein
schnäppchen gewesen
die muss man auch sagen als die
atomenergie in den 50er 60er jahren auch
als politische entscheidung beschlossen
wurde war jedem klar dass man das möchte
aber dass man keine lösung für den müll
hat und die hat man ja bis heute nicht
dazu gibt es auch einen user kommentar
von mv beats auch über youtube der
schreibt schießt das zeug ins weltall
folge ein technisch gesehen oder sagen
wir mal so das wäre natürlich die lösung
den ganzen müll in die sonne zu schießen
dann wäre es hier raus aus der biosphäre
da waren wir total sicher allerdings bis
der müll dahin kommt gibt es etliche
risiken
wir fangen wir an mit der menge man
brauchte bräuchte tausende von raketen
der bauer diverse jetzt kennen
vielleicht findet ja einer in zukunft
eine ganz andere rakete kann ja sein
tausende von raketen die richtung sonne
fliegen müssten
und jetzt ist der der fehlstart quotient
die wäsche
möglichkeit das ist ein fehlstart gibt
ein unglück ist größe ein prozent und
ehrlich gesagt das haben wir schon
erlebt dass raketen kurz nach dem start
mit der mannschaft explodiert sind ich
mir nicht vorstellen was passiert wenn
der tonnen radioaktiven material ist
drauf sind die dann werden
flächendeckend über dem jeweiligen
kontinent möglicherweise die usa
möglicherweise russland egal wo die
raketen losging verteilt wird und wenn
doch die winde ein bisschen ungünstig
stehen haben wirklich alle was davon
also schöne idee
theoretisch kann das funktionieren
praktisch für ausgeschlossen und über
die kosten was der spaß dann uns
steuerzahler am ende noch kosten wird da
denkt man lieber überhaupt nicht nach
das ist utopisch dann lieber nicht ein
endlager dann lieber 2 endlager bauen
das günstiger er kann nicht so absurd
sich das anhört aber das waren ja
tatsächlich folge hat gerade gesagt
vorschläge die auf dem tisch lagen die
amerikaner haben da auch sehr ernsthaft
darüber nachgedacht haben sie das auch
mit in erwägung gezogen
die endlager kommission hat diese
alternativen in der tat geprüft unser
auftrag ist es ein tiefen geologisches
endlager zu finden und gleichzeitig zu
schauen rechts und links gibt es bessere
möglichkeiten nach aktuellem stand von
wissenschaft und technik bietet die
geologie die robusteste barriere gegen
den für den sicheren langzeit einschluss
aber in der tat die alternativen sind
geprüft worden die frage der
raketenstart völlig richtig beantwortet
worden das restrisiko war zu hoch es gab
die variante dass man überprüft hat die
radioaktiven abfälle im packeis
einzulagern
das ist in zeiten des klimawandels keine
wirklich gute idee die frage ob man die
obmann tiefe bohrlöcher macht an der
erdkruste in der hoffnung dass man eine
erdplatte trifft die sich in richtung
erdkern verschieben wurde ebenfalls
überprüft das risiko wurde für zu hoch
befunden
die frage der langzeit zwischenlagerung
über tage wurde geprüft es gibt aber
keine bauwerke die so alt sind und so
lange überdauern dass sie diesen
zeitraum von einer million jahre
überstehen
und deswegen hat die endlager kommission
auf deren grundlagen wie aufgesetzt
haben und arbeiten klar gesagt tiefen
biologische lagerung ist der weg nummer
eins der favorisiert und jetzt verfolgt
wird gleichzeitig aber lernen das
verfahren offenheit für neue
wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse heißt wir
gucken immer auch rechts und links
lagerung über der erde ist ein ganz
gutes stichwort wenn wir uns die
zwischenlagerung angucken und dazu hat
hubert aiwanger
der chef der freien wähler und der
wirtschaftsminister des freistaats
bayern sich heute geäußert mir kommt es
darauf an auch den atommüll die jetzt in
den zwischenlagern ist und nicht mal
ordentlich gegen flugzeugabstürze
teilweise gesichert ist dass wir hier
lagerhallen haben die ersten würden wenn
dort der schwere passagiermaschine rein
fliegt und wir hoffen dass aber die
castoren dort drinnen das aushalten dann
ist es in meinen augen wichtiger jetzt
mal diesen müll zeit noch halbwegs
ordentlich unterzubringen
auch in salzstöcke die schon vorbereitet
sind vielleicht für einige hundert jahre
jetzt sicher genug sind aber nicht zu
sagen für eine million jahre hamas nicht
und deshalb macht mir jetzt 30 jahre gar
nix also das passt nicht zusammen
er sagt hager volker was ist ein gedanke
wenn du an die zwischenlager situation
im moment denkst denke ich dass die
irgendwann voll sind und das geht
relativ schnell weil so viel platz ist
nicht mehr einige haben noch kapazität
aber andere sind schon ziemlich am
anschlag also jülich zum beispiel kann
158 castoren aufnehmen 152 stehen drin
so und das haben jetzt durch die nähe
bei den anderen gibt es ein bisschen
mehr wenn ich jetzt sage auch wir warten
noch mal ein bisschen und stellen die
castoren in diese zwischenlager
dann ist der druck auch weg das endlager
voranzutreiben also ich finde das keine
gute idee und das ist schon richtig dass
die zwischenlager deswegen heißen sie ja
auch zwischenlager im nicht die
sicherheit garantieren die ein endlager
garantieren müssen von daher gesehen
kann man nur sagen so schnell wie
möglich raus aus dem zwischenlager und
naja zehn jahre dauert die planung noch
für das endlager und dann noch mal 20
jahre bau wenn alles gut geht das sind
ja noch 30 jahre
also das ist schon eine lange zeit noch
kam jetzt wie sicher sind die
zwischenlager die zwischenlager sind
sicher heute und in zukunft jedenfalls
bis zu dem zeitpunkt bis zu dem wir ein
endlager gefunden haben die barriere im
zwischenlager bildet der castor behälter
der castor behälter ist ein ziemlich
spezielles produkt er ist sehr dick war
nicht sehr stabil erhält eben
unterschiedliche varianten von
einwirkungen von außen aus und die
hallen die das ganze umgibt die sind im
prinzip ja ich würde sagen ein
wetterschutz sie sind schon auch mehr
aber der eigentliche die eigentliche
barriere die bildet der k
der behälter wir haben ja klare
genehmigungspraxis in der bundesrepublik
das heißt der zwischenlager betreiber
muss beantragen ein solches
zwischenlager betreiben zu können und
muss insofern den sicherheitsnachweis
für den sicheren einschluss in diesen
behältern auch erbringen aber sicher und
richtig ist dass die langzeitsicherheit
am ende des tages nicht über diese
barrieren in form von beton oder in form
von gehältern über tage alleine
gewährleistet werden kann sondern das
geht dann eben nur über ein endlager das
tief in der erde liegt und insofern geht
es schon darum dass wir hier auch tempo
machen damit die zwischen lehrern nicht
zur faktischen endlagern werden weil man
sich eben um die endlagerung nicht mehr
kümmert ja absolut richtig kann ich nur
zustimmen
und na gut wir haben ja gesehen zu was
terroristen alles fähig sind ich will da
auch gar nicht vorstellen
wenn ein flugzeug entführt wird und ein
großer flieger auf so ein zwischenlager
fällt das wäre dann wirklich der
härtetest für die castorbehälter ist
stimmt die die sind das ist
außergewöhnlich hartes material und auch
mehrfach getestet worden
sie hat mich noch an die bilder wo dir
vor fand ich weiß nicht aus welcher höhe
herunter geworfen werden die daten mit
feuer und allen möglichen versucht diese
dinger zu knacken ist es nie gelungen
die sind einfach wirklich gut aber nach
menschlichen beim essen wie es so schön
heißt ist es sicher aber wir haben in
der geschichte gesehen der jüngsten
vergangenheit da gibt es manchmal
aktionen die liegen nicht im
menschlichen ermessen und das ist der
risikofaktor und denen wir sind wir so
klein wie irgend möglich halten nun ist
die situation kein endlager zu haben
keine die uns von anderen ländern in der
welt unterscheidet bislang gibt es
nirgendwo ein endlager außer in finnland
da wird gerade daran gebaut und auch das
verhältnis der finnen zur atomkraft und
auch zu diesem endlager das
unterscheidet sich doch sehr von dem
hier in deutschland die stimmung
ausgelassen wie bei einer klassenfahrt
dabei geht es nicht nach disneyland
sondern 60 meter unter die erde ins
lager für schwach und mittelradioaktiven
atommüll
die sache mit der strahlung scheint hier
niemanden zu stören
ein besuch im kernkraftwerk ist in
finnland nichts außergewöhnliches er ist
sogar im lehrplan vorgeschrieben
ich habe großes vertrauen der betreiber
kümmert sich um alles
jedoch keine leute reinbringen wenn es
gefährlich wäre also ich hab keine angst
die benachbarte kleinstadt in new york
die freut sich über ihren spitznamen
atomkraft gemeinde genauso wie über
sprudelnde gewerbesteuereinnahmen in new
york trägt den beinamen elektrische
gemeinde finnlands wenn erst mal das
neue kraftwerk 3 am netz ist wird dieser
titel sicher noch bekannte atomkraft ja
bitte
die finnen haben schlicht ein sehr
entspanntes verhältnis zur kernenergie
er kann jetzt was glauben sie kommen die
deutschen auch irgendwann an den punkt
oder nicht
wir haben sicherlich eine andere
geschichte zur kernenergie nutzung als
die finden oder auch die schwedin ich
glaube nicht dass wir zu ähnlichen
verhältnissen kommen aber mein wunsch
wäre und das ist ja auch der anspruch
dieses verfahrens dass wir einen konsens
haben in der gesellschaft es ist müll
der in deutschland verursacht worden ist
insofern brauchen den endlager standort
in deutschland
und dann gemeinsam nach dem wichtigen
oder für den richtigen weg zu streiten
das ist glaube ich lohnenswert und
insofern einen anderen nüchternen umgang
der nüchternen umgang zu finden und zu
definieren
das wäre natürlich wünschenswert aber
dafür ist auch in der vergangenheit
natürlich viel vertrauen kaputtgegangen
und das muss man jetzt erstmal wieder
erarbeiten und da sind natürlich die
staatlichen institutionen auch die bg
gefragt volker finnische verhältnisse in
deutschland möglich mehr kann ich mir
ehrlich gesagt nicht so vorstellen ich
glaube die die finden sind von
vornherein ganz anders rangegangen
wir haben das sozusagen ja wertfrei
betrachter hat gesagt okay wir haben
atomkraftwerke übrigens was die finnen
damit machen für die ist es auch nur
eine übergangslösung die machen das so
lange bis die erneuerbaren energien so
gut am start sind dass man wirklich
sagen kann ohne stromlücke ohne angst zu
haben dass da irgendwie das licht
ausgeht dann gehen die auch aus der
atomwirtschaft das nun mal am rand aber
ich glaube sie an anders kommuniziert
sie haben an den schulen erklärt was ist
eigentlich ein atomkraft wie geht das
eigentlich wie es der
brennstoffkreislauf alle schulen oder
nahezu alle schulen in finnland haben
irgendwann mal den ausflug gebucht in
dieses kraftwerk zu die in dieses in
diesem endlager was da sich im bau
befindet das kann man sagen
das ist ja herr beste propaganda die
wollen die alle zu atom jüngern machen
gut der meinung kann man sein aber ich
glaube diese art von
öffentlichkeitsarbeit die frühzeitige
erklärung was funktioniert da eigentlich
technisch und auch wo sind denn die
risiken auf was muss man achten welche
berufe braucht man denn eigentlich um
den sicherheit dort zu garantieren das
sind alles dinge die bei uns in dem maße
nicht stattgefunden haben wir waren
sozusagen glock ja durch die politische
kernkraftdebatte die einfach genau diese
kommunikativen möglichkeiten verhindert
hat und dass wenn man so will rechts ich
oder hat sich gerächt und jetzt haben
wir die chance das anders zu machen und
es wäre natürlich ganz super denn im
laufe dieses verfahrens genau diese
defizite aufgearbeitet werden und
einfach klar gemacht wird dass ein
endlager für atomaren müll nicht
irgendeine müllkippe ist wo man das zeug
rein schweiß in klammern die erfahrung
haben wir in der asse gemacht da muss
jetzt alles wieder mühevoll ausklammert
werden was man da lose rhein geworfen
hat nein bei dem neuen endlager ist ja
auch eine anforderung dass es 500 jahre
lang möglich sein muss die null wieder
rauszuholen
weil man sagt es kann sein es gibt neue
erkenntnisse oder die geologischen
gutachten waren doch nicht so
treffsicher wie man gehofft hat das sind
alles neue erkenntnisse und darüber muss
man reden das muss man wirklich sehr
sehr weit verbreiten und möglicherweise
tatsächlich auch vielleicht an die
schulen gehen vielleicht an die
universitäten gehen oder wenn es
öffentlich rechtliche fernsehen führen
und vielleicht ist nicht nur auf
deutscher ebene lösen sondern auch auf
europäischer ebene fragt gerade einen
user über facebook kann man das problem
nicht auf eu ebene lösen als gemeinsames
projekt
es ist schon so dass wir das thema
europäische sprechen es gibt sehr enge
forschungskooperation wir sind
beispielsweise als bundes gesellschaft
für endlagerung beteiligt sowohl am
schweizer projekt das heißt beteiligt
insofern als dass wir unserem alter tage
labor beteiligen wir haben ja in
deutschland traditionell sehr viel
wissen über das würzige steinsalz
weniger über ton und kristallin und
diesen business nachteil sozusagen den
versuchen wir auch auszugleichen über
beteiligungen an internationalen
forschungsprojekten insbesondere
gleichzeitig verbietet ist das
völkerrecht jetzt diese radioaktiven
abfälle
zu exportieren in andere länder ich
glaube es ist auch wichtig dass wenn wir
über das thema endlagerung sprechen wir
innerhalb der europäischen union nach
gleichen maßstäben vorgehen das gleiche
sicherheitsmaßstäbe aber schon versuchen
jeder für sich dieses problem zu lösen
in enger kooperation anders angesprochen
sie haben ja heute gesehen mit der
vorlage des zwischenberichtes
teilgebiete dass die republik durchaus
gut geeignet ist wir sind eines der
wenigen länder dass alle drei
wirtsgesteine hat salz ton und
kristallin und wenn man die europäische
lösung will dann wäre ich nicht würde
ich nicht ausschließen dass die in
deutschland sich am ende manifestiert in
einem endlagerstandort
nun wäre ja noch eine andere also nicht
eine andere aber ein konstruktiver
anderer lösungsansatz zu sagen wenn die
wissenschaft es zulässt fragt der
zuschauer oder user pavel stark kann
nicht auf neue erkenntnisse zur
aufbereitung oder entschärfung des mülls
gehofft werden so dass in zum beispiel
100 jahren diese optimiert entsorgt oder
weiterverwertet werden kann also das aus
müll ein wertstoff im sinne eines wertes
wird dem man irgendwie für irgendwas
gutes verwenden oder einsetzen kann ja
dass das kann durchaus möglich sein ist
gibt ja durchaus forschungen die eine
völlig neue generation von reaktoren
versuchen herzustellen das ist in den
usa zum beispiel ein thema wird unter
anderem von der bill gates stiftung
finanziell massiv unterstützt genau aus
diesem grund um möglicherweise mit den
abgebrannten brennelementen die so zu
verarbeiten in einem neuen reaktortyp
dass die gefährdung durch die
radioaktivität dramatisch untergeht hat
diverse andere nachteile da geht es um
hohe temperaturen die einen reaktor dann
außerhalb muss wesentlich höher als im
moment usw das sind alles überlegungen
und deswegen ist es ja so dass das
endlager ich habe es ja vorhin gerade
schon mal gesagt das endlager eben nicht
zugemacht wird und dann war es das
sondern man kann ein paar hundert jahre
lang noch mal rein und wenn es diese
neuen technischen möglichkeiten gibt
dann kann man die dann auch anwenden
kann man wenn genug creator ist wenn der
politische wille da ist das muss immer
dazu gehört aber eins würde ich gern
noch zu einem sondern gar nichts sagen
klar der atommüll ist nun mal da und wir
müssen uns darum kümmern und jedes land
hat die verantwortung dass im eigenen
land zu tun und wenn wir das gut
machen dann kann deutschland
möglicherweise für viele andere länder
das ziel vorgeben vorgeben wie es
einfach geht durch die ingenieurleistung
die da drin steckt durch das verfahren
durch dieses transparente verfahren
das hat den anderen bereichen auch prima
funktioniert bei den erneuerbaren
energien durch das
erneuerbare-energien-gesetz das war auch
ein exportschlager in die welt und viele
länder haben das nachgemacht also es
steckt dort auch eine tolle chance drin
dass deutschland wirklich eine
technologie ein verfahren entwickelt was
man exportieren kann und das glaube ich
muss man auch dazusagen nicht immer
meine güte wie kriegen dann
möglicherweise ein endlager harris muss
irgendwo stehen das ist nun mal fakt und
jetzt müssen wir das beste draus machen
und frage zum abschluss folgt 2030 31
soll der prozess abgeschlossen sein 2050
soll das lager stehen glaubst du daran
ach ich glaube dass herr k s und die die
truppe mit der arbeit die sind so unter
druck die müssen das hinkriegen
und ich glaube auch egal welche
bundesregierung als nächstes kommt das
ist ein projekt ein generationenprojekt
das muss einfach funktionieren denn wir
haben es ja eben gesprochen je länger es
dauert desto größer wird das risiko dass
dann eben doch irgendetwas passiert was
eben nicht in menschlichem ermessen ist
da sind wir wieder bei den
zwischenlagern das endlager also 20 50
sollte es wirklich in betrieb gehen das
war schon richtig gut
er kann jetzt ich erwähnt an der stelle
noch mal markus söder und stellt die
frage an sie nochmal 2050 steht das
endlager dann jahr 2050 steht das
endlager da bin ich 66 jahre alt und
kann dann vielleicht bald in rente gehen
sofern passt das gut aber spaß beiseite
in diese zeiträume haben hier sehr
ernste hintergründe wir nehmen das ernst
wir arbeiten intensiv daran dieses ziel
20 31 zu erreichen ich halte das auch
für machbar das hängt daran ob alle auch
in der tat den willen haben mit zu
ziehen ich glaube dass das gelingen kann
der zeitplan darf nicht zu lasten der
beteiligung gehen das heißt wir müssen
schon einerseits schnell arbeiten als
vorhaben trägerin und gleichzeitig
gewissenhaft und bedürfen die
beteiligung nicht zu kurz kommen lassen
denn es ist nicht geholfen wenn es uns
nicht gelingt zu vermitteln wie wir
vorgehen transparenz vermitteln wie wir
vorgehen beides gehört zusammen
aber ich halte das für machbar und
verschwand aber
daran arbeiten wir auch sagt steffen kam
jetzt vielen dank an dieser stelle nach
berlin
volker angriffs vielen dank für den
besuch im studio und ihnen und euch zu
hause vielen dank fürs zuschauen und
mitmachen einen schönen abend noch bis
bald tisch